wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
zum wohl der bürger wieder hallo mein
tisch ist ja frei aus männlichen
was hättest du denn gern ich möchte
heute kein fleisch essen
ich würde mal die karte max karte sag
mal wie war eigentlich dann ausflug naja
was wieso nur naja es war unorganisiert
das wetter war schlecht und der rest der
gruppe stand mit einem bein im grab
ich mein ja nur es hat mir aber trotzdem
gut gefallen
hast du jemand kennengelernt
also leute wenn man am besten auf reisen
kennen wir beide haben uns auch auf
einer reise kennengelernt ja aber die
anderen in der gruppe waren wirklich
nicht sehr interessant warum nicht sehr
interessant weil der klub der rentner
sich nur über krankheiten unterhält
okay das ist wirklich nervig
schicke smartphone wusste gar nicht was
du sonst hat sich das gehört mir nicht
und das ist von jacques wer ist lang
[Musik]